aujourd'hui le numérique représente 2%
l'empreinte environnementale si on reste
sur la trajectoire actuelle en 2040 on
sera à 7 %
cette proposition de loi c'est le fruit
d'un travail qui est issue d'une mission
d'information
que j'ai souhaité il ya maintenant plus
de deux ans j'ai constaté qu' il n'y
avait pas en tout cas à l'échelle du
territoire national d'éléments donc
technique concrets qui permettait de se
donner une idée de ce qu'était
l'empreinte environnementale du
numérique ces travaux nous ont incités à
aller plus loin et aller plus loin
c'était traduire ses propositions dans
un texte de loi c'est ce qu'on a fait ce
texte a ensuite été inscrits voté à
l'unanimité ici au sénat ce texte est un
texte fondateur et le premier en europe
on
va trouver un axe qui concerne la
sensibilisation l'éducation l'éco
conception toute la partie plus
intellectuel de l'aide de la chose
ensuite on va trouver d'autres pillées
quelques donc la sobriété en termes de
contenu c'est faire en sorte qu' on est
vite
limité qu'on évite des vidéos qui se
s'impose à l'utilisateur on va trouver
aussi ensuite tout ce qui est
obsolescence auto naissance logiciel de
sa naissance matériel qui là aussi sous
s'impose souvent à l'utilisateur malgré
lui on n'a pas vu je veux dire qu'ils
s'intéressent aux terminaux et notamment
donc à faire en sorte que la durée de
vie de ces terminaux soit prolongée un
chiffre aujourd'hui la durée de vie d'un
terminal c 23 mois en france coût
environnemental d'un terminal c'est 80 %
du coût total mais que si on fait un
effort sur cet axe là on va vite avoir
des gains donc on a proposé justement à
ce que vont favoriser le réemploi qu on
motive les gens à garder ces matériels
on a aussi un volet sur l'aspect
infrastructures réseaux notamment les
data center et puis un volet donc ainsi
cet incitatif pour que les collectivités
intègrent dans leurs politiques
publiques donc ce sujet
[Musique]